good
morning millennials we were off they
never had a little behind
i'm sorry usually i hear the click of
the keyboard and today i didn't hear it
so i was just like giving myself a
second but i'm sorry
good morning millennials happy tuesday
we did it we made it past the monday
after a long weekend
and we deserves a pat we deserve a pat
on the back you know we deserve a
vacation
so true but it is a sneaky tuesday i
woke up this morning like yesterday was
such a hard long day and it's like it's
only
tuesday i actually had the most wild
dream that like
george lopez's publicist was like
hounding us to get george on the show
and did we have george on the toast
on the toast um so then it was like it
was the day of and george like wanted to
come on like this particular day and
like we literally our fingers weren't
working so we like
couldn't get the email written and i
think it was probably my subconscious
like thinking that i'm always sabotaging
like my own business you know what i
mean
sure if i had to look into it that's
what i think a shrink would say so did
we have george on the toaster did we not
we woke up before he was scheduled to
arrive oh you got to go back to sleep
i know that's like the worst when you
really are having like an amazing dream
like zac efron's your boyfriend or
something
and then you wake up and you're like
[ __ ] go back to sleep and you can maybe
go back to sleep but you never get back
to the dream
for sure i feel like the worst is like
i'm always just having such an involved
dream
when my alarm goes off and it's like i
need to finish it out it's not like an
amazing dream my life isn't i'm not
you know right didn't win the lottery
but like i just need to see
what happens here it's like just the
middle of a movie and you gotta get up
that's also the weird thing about dreams
like i find like the the timing of
dreams to be so suspicious how it's like
why is it always that i have to wake up
right when the dream is getting good or
like right when something's supposed to
happen
or i've been waiting for something to
happen in the dream and it's like oh my
alarm goes off or how sometimes my alarm
plays a part in my dream oh of course
i'm at a club
turn your phone off yeah it's like i'm
at a club and like that's the song
they're playing and then i realize like
it's actually my alarm like how does my
brain know you know
yeah no for me it's always like in my
dream i'm turning it off and then but
it's still ringing and it's driving me
mad because i'm like turning it off but
i'm just not awake to turn it off that's
the worst you ever have
like a dream where you're snoozing and
you dream that like you got up and
brushed your teeth and like oh yeah like
i
i have started my day yeah and then it's
like oh i'm so great i'm not feeling
tired at all and it's because you're
still asleep
yep i love talking about dreams i think
it's one of the most interesting
topics of conversation are you being
sarcastic yes yeah because
i think actually talking conceptually
about dreams is somewhat interesting but
hearing other people talk about like
their dreams that's like one of my like
core pillars
like i don't want to hear about your
dreams just like i know to repeat myself
i know i hate when people talk about
their dreams but you know but you're
talking about dream subconscious not
like their hopes and wishes for the
world right
because honestly if somebody seems to
hear about someone's hopes and whatever
somebody just tuned into the show and
you're like i don't want to hear about
your dreams like man this girl is mean
you know like she's had a rough year i
actually rewatched our episode of the
toast yesterday because i thought it was
so funny and
we were just being so funny i just loved
yesterday's episode
you know when else we were being funny
well two other times one we did a
patreon episode where we started to
answer vogue 73 questions
and it's so funny because the questions
are like interesting questions very
abstract yeah and we
one of the questions is like tell us
something that we don't know about you
and we come to the conclusion that you
guys like literally know everything
about us
but i found that some of the questions
like you are learning some new things
about us
you know it's just like questions coming
at you
no one has ever asked me like what would
the soundtrack of your life be called
you know yeah that wasn't a question
oh maybe i skipped that one because it
was on or like if your if your life was
a musical what would the marquee say
yeah that was a tough question but if
you want to hear our answers head over
to patreon.com morning
toast also what is so and then we were
also being funny again
on instagram live like that was just
such a funny treat for anyone who caught
jackie and i instagram live last night
it was so funny
we were just being insane you know was
that it was that hour honestly it was
like that's when we when we facetime
like that's our conversation
but it was just live for everyone to see
so it was funny for those watching on
youtube you might have
noticed my new mug that i'm sipping out
of it's actually some new merch and you
can get it at shopmorningtoast.com
it is for those not watching on youtube
it is a beautiful black mug that says
thirst monster on it because i love to
drink and i'm quite thirsty
yes you are also what is so crazy is
that today is december 1st
i know you know when i was going to bed
last night it was 1202 and i remember
i'm like ben i turned over i'm like it's
december and he was like that's crazy
like sick
i remember last december truly like it
was yesterday because nothing has
happened since then that is
so [ __ ] crazy like december that one
really got me
i know you know it's like a little
freaking me out about it is that like 20
20 is almost
over which i'm glad for because
everyone's like 20 20 is the worst but
everyone was like 20 20 is going to be
better but like
2020 is almost over and there's no road
to better right so
what i was in the middle of saying was
that like i know we just finished
finishing each other's sandwiches like
it's not getting better so 2021 like at
the beginning like might also be like a
big
steaming pile of [ __ ] and i think we all
collectively need to like
accept that because our expectations are
like way too high like we're going to
wake up on january 1st like everything's
going to be better reset
no it's not because it's already it's
only 30 days away yeah and nothing has
changed
that's so scary it's so scary it's very
upsetting and depressing to think about
yeah i'm speaking of the lottery that
you literally just said five minutes ago
i've been like holding on to that
transition
i do i'm glad that you could remember
what you were going to say
i started lost speaking of the lottery
one of the characters i don't want to
spoil it but i'm not going to watch it
and everybody else already has one of
the characters like who uh
is on the island before it was on island
won the lottery back at home and now
that's irrelevant
isn't it clearly and like nobody
believes him that he's worth 156 million
dollars we're like yeah sure hurley
whatever you say
um and i will talk about in the tv recap
but just remind me because i wanted to
talk about it yesterday
and i wasn't able to also do you
remember um like two weeks ago when
our last episode when we were talking
about something and i couldn't remember
what i wanted to say
yes i remembered it do you think anyone
cares should i say what it is i remember
what it is too now
yes say it it's always nice i've been
having these moments like yesterday we
were talking about
on the patreon we were talking about
dave portnoy and i was trying to think
of a phrase
and i couldn't think of it and so i just
like stumbled but what i wanted to say
was he's a creature of habit
right because he's always at the same
restaurant i don't know what i said oh
yeah yeah yeah i was like he's a lover
of singing
he's like a one time guy
but what i was going to say two years
ago it's so important that when you like
when you remind me remember stuff that
you need to share
and that you follow up yeah what i was
going to say two weeks
we were talking about that viral video
of the kids from michigan and how we
were so obsessed and how eeny meeny miny
moe lover is such a good song
and if you if you need a reminder i'm
pretending i'm number one
was that english or didn't i have a
seven on my shirt
don't leave me out here dancing alone
you can't make up your mind well you got
you can't leave me out here dancing in
the water okay mine mine
mine mine so what i was gonna say was
that i was really waiting for justin
bieber to like address
the viral video like in any way like
celebrities love to get it i'm like
they love to be annoying and like get in
on viral moments yeah and actually
justin bieber went live
right after um right before our episode
of the toast and i was like in bed
watching his live commenting like have
you seen the video
and i just wanted him to like
acknowledge me or at least like the
video and he didn't but that was the
anecdote i was going
to share whilst on the toast two weeks
ago you were going to share you were
going to say
i hope justin bieber acknowledges it no
and tell my story about me being no the
live was after
no wasn't it wasn't it was going to tell
my story about like being a big loser
like commenting on justin bieber's live
like have you seen the viral video
i'm sure he has but he should have said
something about it yeah like
i'm sure the streams for eenie meenie
miney mo lover are so much higher
up astronomical yeah also you know what
time of year it is and this like really
excites me
christmas spotify end of year data data
data season we'll be getting our data
you know what so i was just like
um looking through photos from this time
last year and i saw my screenshots from
my
decade in the review i got it and then i
was looking at like my 2014 most played
song it was a little mixed song that i
didn't recognize the title
i was like how is this my most played
song so i went to listen to it and i
remember it now of course
and it's so amazing like now it's like
going to be my most listened of the
month
i'm curious if other music platforms are
going to do that because it was like so
popular last year
and it's like spotify's thing but i
wonder if like apple music will do their
own version of it since it's like so
popular i think they have such limited
data
i don't think so i think a lot of people
like if you either like we use
exclusively spotify so we can't imagine
having like any apple music data but
like
a lot of people do use apple music i
only use apple music to buy songs on
itunes if i want to put them in a vlog
for sure or like a video star yeah or
we're doing toast radio
yeah but other people like use it as
their main streaming platform and i'm
just curious like people are going to
steal spotify's idea
speaking of toast radio don't worry
we're not doing another episode
your loins but our holiday toast radio
episode from last year like still
applies to this year so if you're
looking like for a radio program
that'll get you into the holiday spirit
might i suggest toast radio
christmas 2019. did you watch cma
country christmas i
did not me neither because and i really
[ __ ] myself last night because i was
saying
i needed to read the the book for the
redheads and i started it and
last night i had some free time on my
hands because there was nothing on tv
and instead i started a new season of
married at first sight
and it was up until like one o'clock
watching it and i was just like i'm not
that girl anymore
i don't want to be that girl like it's
just it's upsetting and i think it's
because bruno sweets is at camp
and your whole balance is awesome he
really got me on such a good schedule
dare i say
a sleep schedule yeah and now it's like
i'm up till one i'm like waking up in
such a huff and it's
the drama it's not good the drama is
real well speaking of drama tons of
things well
not tons i would say like mediocre news
here and there but you know we can make
a mountain out of a molehill here at the
morning toast and that's what we do
every monday through friday on our
youtube channel so make sure you're
subscribed
and i think i think we could get right
into it i think it could be time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
i'm so glad you brought that up jackie
because you know what i've been dying to
talk about it for a minute
today's episode very appropriately it's
december 1st it is officially the
holiday season the christmas tree and
the big reef
wreath rita wreath are up in my building
which means it's time for today's
episode to be brought to you by love
book
a personalized gift that helps express
your feelings that might be difficult to
say out loud
a lot of the love book customers use
love book to revisit their fondest
memories or to list the reasons why they
love someone
love books are completely customizable
and you can use them however you like
so if there's someone in your life who
like and just like a simple you know
like material item just
won't cut it and you really want to like
show them how much they mean to you
lovebook is fabulous it's like a totally
customized book that you can make for
anyone in your life
they have express options if you just
want to like kind of do something um
more generic but you can really like
customize almost every aspect of it
it's pretty fabulous you can create
characters that just like you
look just like you or the person you're
giving it to um with their features
their clothes
um and you can even choose their
hairstyles so while you have the option
to customize each page
and personalize it as much as you like
you can also use the express option and
create a complete book in just a few
minutes
they are the perfect gift for any
occasion but especially for
anniversaries birthdays and obviously
christmas coming up
for the person you love most get them a
love book it's so cute like literally
the story of jackie and claudia i would
do like
jackie and claudia like magical hosts
jackie and claudia and the magical
microphone you know something like that
um
if you want to visit lovebookonline.com
use the link lovebookonline.comtoast
to receive a special 20 discount for
your for our listeners
again that's lovebookonline.com
toast for a special 20 discount it's
great for the person in your life who
has everything and someone who just like
you really need to tell how much you
love and you know if we've learned
anything this year it's like you just
gotta tell the people
you love that you love them right and
show them with a love book
online dot com shows okay first story
love is in the air a source is saying
that rihanna is dating long time friend
asap rocky after
months of romance rumors i heard about
this
the news comes after uh page six
reported that the couple was spotted
having dinner with friends at the
beatrice inn in new york over the
weekend
and now a source is telling people that
they are dating brianna asap rocky
together so let's let's go through
rihanna's like most recent dating
history because yeah she had that very
short
fling with drake and that was everything
of the sword even though like he like
embarrassed himself and like it was just
so clear like he was so into her
and she was not and honestly i don't
think him and his ego like have ever
recovered from that because it was like
really embarrassing like when he made
that speech it's like the vms or
whatever like she swerved on him like
hardcore like just so not interested
then she was dating that like prince
right
the billionaire hassan jameel yeah and
they were three years for for a long
time and i actually thought that was
going to be it for her but it recently
came to an end rihanna's just so
interesting because she's a very
rare type of celebrity who is like
a-list and never has to lift a finger do
you know what i mean like
she worked really hard on her music and
then her um
clothing savage makeup and now she's
just at this like amazing place in her
life where she's just raking it in
and she doesn't have to step out to like
work as a celebrity like she is just
eternally famous
and now she could just focus like i feel
like everything around her is thriving
like her businesses are so successful
now she's gonna focus on her and like
maybe it's just been the guy next to her
all along you know
maybe or like i don't know some part of
this story just makes me feel like they
were at dinner with friends and
everyone's like
making this more than it is i feel like
people are always shipping rihanna with
someone and she's like
no who do you ship brianna with oh
i feel like for a long time it was drake
but now that you're like reminding me of
that like
very sad vmas
i just like that's too sad no i know it
was like
for all the people who were like really
rooting for them it was so exciting
and then it wasn't yeah because i really
thought that was going to be it for them
it's like finally
i think that this is a super cute couple
yeah i don't know if i see her with
someone though like
in the music industry neither do i
that's why i actually think the guy she
was dating before like
very very rich like cosmopolitan man of
the world like that's actually exactly
what she needed
right and maybe that's why i was so
successful they dated for three years
right we need another one
we do another like rich mysterious tall
dark handsome man
yeah international man of mystery she
needs a businessman bow like
everyone needs a businessman bow go get
yourself one
that's what it you know it really boils
down to it's like if you
lay your head on your pillow and you
look over and there's not a businessman
bow there it's like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
what are you doing yeah no it's so true
because you want to know what's so great
about businessman beau
businessmen beau sorry um is that
obviously their businessmen so like they
could provide for you and like that's
ideal you know you just
i'm very progressive but i'm still a
woman who just wants to be taken care of
and i don't think that's crazy to say
like
i just want to be taken care of but also
like businessmen like they have a good
head on their shoulders
most of the time and i just feel like
they're they're good partners you know
yeah i also feel like a businessman beau
when you are an a-list celebrity i think
like a common theme with celebs is like
people
are taking advantage of them like you
know they have managers agents they're
paying all these people all these
different things and a businessman beau
can come in and run it like a business
you know who i think is dan
beau actually a quintessential
businessman who i
i don't think i don't think we ever
would have thought but now that i think
about it
he's really the perfect business not for
rihanna but just in general i think i
know what you're going to say
okay if you by the way i just want to
say if you guess what i'm thinking
because it's
so like random i seriously you have to
kiss me on the lips
no then yeah but it's my gift like i'll
get you on the lips
if i guess what you're thinking i will
give you
dead ass five hundred dollars okay i'm
going to give you my guess now you only
get one
jason holy [ __ ] oh my god
i can't believe you knew that he's a
businessman because what you just
described about like
why it's so great to like be a
successful woman with a businessman beau
who looks like always looking out for
you like
that's really how i feel like jason
tartik and kaitlyn's relationship is
like so mutually beneficial i feel like
he is just like so caring about her
business and he's really really smart
like finance wise 100 and even when he
went on the bachelor like he went on as
a businessman yeah like
when he started dating caitlyn after the
show like he came into the relationship
like
as a businessman and and offered his
services
jackie like freaking out and by the way
i'm not paying you 500
like obviously you guys we have this all
on tv
that's insane um no but also i feel like
when he was on the toast he was like
talking about how they work together and
it really is this like
great like celebrity business and a
relationship no and like
of course a relationship is about love
but it's also about like living together
and co-existing and like creating a life
and i just feel like your partner and i
feel like they have literally like the
most ideal relationship when it comes to
their business like
because caitlyn has all these things
going on jason has this like huge
background like finance business like
management and he's just like over here
managing and it's like so ideal
yeah no i can't believe the business i
knew you
that is so crazy we really spend too
much time together we have one
brain yeah but no that's exactly what it
is and like look how happy they are
they are proof of our theory that
everyone needs a business member a
hundred percent
or businessman gal whatever your
preferences are like you just need a
businessman in your ad
a business business person a business
person yeah
yeah no it's it's good yeah that was
crazy
that was crazy what was the story oh
rihanna yeah
so i actually agree with you i could see
like everyone just being like dramatic
here and trying to like make that happen
but also this would be a cute couple
agreed yeah one of my biggest regrets is
not going to the ante tour at barclay
center yeah i agree with that
do you have like do you have like
monumental um things concert regrets
i mean obviously the time bruno mars was
here and i was sick but like i was sick
what was i gonna do i really couldn't go
yeah when when the life of pablo tour
kanye's was at msg and i asked ben to
get me tickets and he said yeah and like
i'm always like
i'm always like in charge in my house
like i'm always the one like making the
plans and ben was like let me do it like
i want to get
get us tickets i'm like great and of
course literally at the night of the
concert i like for like literally
totally forgotten about it
i saw your [ __ ] instagram story that
you were there and i literally did not
see that was the one with the floating
stage yeah i did not speak to bed i'm
like look i
i handed over the plants to you and
we're sitting in bed on wednesday night
like
that was one of my biggest regrets and
rihanna at barclay center
yeah i'm sure if i keep thinking i can
think of more
but like those are the ones that like
haunt you like especially now there's
like no concerts and it's like you're
thinking of all the concerts you missed
i know but don't you ever feel like
sometimes you would go to a concert and
it's like really
i got all like i'm like sitting there
board waiting for it to be over no
because you want to know why you are a
concert [ __ ] like you just go to
concerts because like
like i go to dinner do you know what i
mean i will only go to a concert if i'm
obsessed and that's how i like i always
have a 10 out of 10 time at concerts
because i will not go unless and and
then when i do go like i will spend the
extra money on
great seats like yeah you just go oh uh
random man in
times square margo let's go like that's
what you guys do so funny because my
time hop is like
me margo dana and nicole went to like
barclays for 947 like country
oh that actually sounds like sam hump
performed but it was right after the dui
but he did an amazing job okay
yeah but that's what i also feel like
concerts are the highlight of my life
like when i think about when i'm like
happiest the most
you know endorphins in the air serotonin
in my brain it's when i'm at a concert
and so it's like okay maybe not every
concert is gonna be that experience but
like i'm gonna be on the road to
happiness why would i just go to this
one
i really just can't believe you guessed
jason tardik like i don't know i
i it's not that surprising it's not no
because like
we just have like if you said to me like
we just have things that like we
we know yeah and like things that we
know about each other like if you were
like
oh what's an example of paparazzi being
invasive like
dennis yeah i'd have to think hard about
it but then i would say dennis's funeral
yeah
yeah okay some more romance news tick
tock star addison wray confirms she's
dating bryce hall for the second time
why are you sticking your tongue out is
that what the kids are doing
no i don't know the kids are doing this
no i do not support this i do not
endorse i think this is like the most
the worst decision addison could have
made and i feel like we come on here on
this show and we're like
such big fans of addison and we say like
everything she's doing in her career is
just like so stellar whoever's managing
her as a genius
and i think that's this is a huge
mistake i really do and margot
is like their number one fan i know she
was i thought that we ship
no i thought bryce in the harbor is
nothing of the sort
is she has she always been dating bryce
they've been like on and off
but they've been off for a while and now
this is always like the tick tocker
she's involved yes there's no other
there's no other talker so first of all
i just think like from a business
perspective
i think that addison could date
literally anyone else and it would be
like so good for her
like business her celebrity she's a
beautiful girl like who wouldn't want to
date her like i actually think
she could find someone better in terms
of celebrity okay
i also just i'm on you know all the
shady tick tock pages tick-tock room
like i know a lot about bryce hall like
i know he literally punched a waiter
because the waiter told him not to vape
in a restaurant like
he's an animal and i just don't think
that's who addison should be like
hanging out with and associating herself
with
and i saw like some videos of him like
kissing a girl this weekend in
like a bar or something like so if i
know that addison knows that and i just
like don't think that this is the wisest
decision for her
and like above all like he's just not my
type like i think addison is so cute and
beautiful and she could do better
oh wow okay so and the truckers for
addison are agreeing with me
wow and they're backing up because
they're like leaving they're getting out
of the port
set they're getting out of the port they
are backing out well i mean i just was
gonna ship because i
stand here um but you've changed my mind
no it's just
i don't think that this is right and i
agree she's a young girl and like she
probably feels safe with him
and i totally get and i agree with you
that like she could be dating someone
and her star could rise completely like
obviously we know he's married to stasi
baby but
no no centennial yeah it's just like i
think bryce hall gets so much out of his
relationship with addison and i don't
know what addison gets out of it like
i think he just brings her down and i
said what i said love
maybe so let's go on a pause mute break
while this rear truck
so they back it up so anyway i'm like
screaming just to like get over it
yeah but of course now it's quiet yeah
of course
okay should we yeah okay three two
one so of course like the minute we
go on mute it stops i'm like i'm truly
one day away
from opening up this window and
literally flashing my titties and be
like i will do this every day if you
just shut the [ __ ] up from 10 to 11.
they'll go crazy if you do that no but
i'll say
you'll get this every day but if you're
just completely silent from 10 to 11 no
trucks backing up
except on tuesdays truckers for tasha
have to show up oh for sure we love them
also i feel like this news about addison
makes you just want to do a pouty face
for sure and then the renegade like i
just
i know margo's obsessed with them but
that's because you know margo's young
and reckless and i'm not and margo so i
think margo loves addison just like we
love addison but she probably loves her
more and like
when margot stands she stands all facets
yeah
and she's not she doesn't choose she
she wants what's best for you yeah
marvel's like margo's just the exact
type of person you want in your corner
when you're um a celebrity yeah so she
she stands all the way she's loyal like
to a fault i
i admire it yeah i do but i'm i'm
looking at this from just like a
reasonable i'm a mature
20 um six-year-old woman is that a woman
yeah yeah 20 20 yeah um and i'm just
looking at this from all different
possible perspectives and i think
business-wise she could do better and
then also just like relationship-wise
she could do better too
okay i think that's a fair assessment
and i would just love to be on this
journey of like
watching addison ray like navigate young
hollywood elite and like dating around
you know they'll be like fun for her
yeah but there's still like more time
like this is just there's time she's
still only like
19. there's time curious time
open me up and it's gonna be giving me
give me no compasses give me no signs
this is beautiful thank you okay ready
for our next story this is like really
big news is it the really big news
that's brought to you by noom
yes that's [ __ ] crazy another one
that's the second one today
another one another one today's episode
is brought to you
by noom the habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food
through personalized courses getting in
shape doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weight or a magic
number on the scale
it's about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself if fitting
into your favorite pair of jeans is a
goal then great
but there are many reasons why you might
want to practice self-care and every
person is different
i actually feel that wholeheartedly
because like while i look amazing in
pretty much every piece of clothing that
i own sometimes when i like treat my
body like [ __ ] like it feels like [ __ ]
which is something i never really
expected so every now and then you
really just gotta
take care of yourself i get really tired
when i don't really eat well
and nume is here to help because it's
not a diet
it is a habit changing solution and
it's a healthy and easy to stick to way
of life no food is considered good bad
or off limits on newm
they teach you moderation and it can be
used in conjunction with pre-existing
diets
if you want noom doesn't tell you what
to do and what not to do they basically
just teach you how to look inside your
own mind
and make decisions for yourself and one
of the things people love about it most
and i know jackie does
is that they have one of the biggest and
most accurate food databases available
that lets you track your meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance when you're doing
food tracking it's so nice to have all
like so many options of things in the
food database because you don't want to
have to input all the calories
or the wrong thing right so it makes it
really easy
something that like food you know
writing down everything that you eat can
be laborious but not with new
nume is asking you to commit to just 10
minutes a day for yourself and if you go
off track there's no shaming just tips
to help you get back on track tomorrow
you don't have to change it all in one
day small steps make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noon
n-o-o-m-dot com slash
toast what do you have to lose visit
noom.com
toast to start your trial today that's n
o o m
dot com slash toast okay the big news
felicity huffman has scored an acting
role this is crazy her first acting role
after her prison
stint that was really fast yeah the
desperate housewives alumna who served
just 11 days of a two-week jail sentence
last year
has signed on to star in an untitled abc
comedy
inspired by the life of susan savage
owner of triple a baseball sacramento
river
cats according to deadline that sounds
like a really good show
um in general yeah i was i didn't know
what the show was about it was a comedy
i was really hoping it was loosely based
off of what she went through
right no but it's about like a powerful
woman a powerful woman
baseball team owner comedy love to see
it the project will co-star
zach godeskin who was in the peanut
butter falcon
and um a bunch of other people who are
working on this project so when i think
of felicity huffman and like her career
you can't help but
want to compare it to lori laflin's
right and i feel like lori laughlin was
just in like such a worse position in
this whole college admission scandal for
a million reasons one
her charges legally were more because
she paid more money
two she came from full house hallmark
channel
very wholesome family content and she
was let go from everything immediately
and will most likely not be
back on those networks and doing that
type of content because it is so
family-friendly and like christian
values and
they just don't want to be associated
with that and then
um she also legally like her her case
went on for
almost a year longer like she's in
prison right now right yeah
and felicity huffman got out last year
like hers went on for so much longer
i don't know why like i'm sure it was
like her lawyer's um
recommendation but like i just feel like
the two situations which were similar
even though they had different charges
like
i so would have preferred to be felicity
huffman yes i mean
of course but i also think that just
like lori laughlin was on all these like
family shows and family networks
felicity hoffman like like we said at
the beginning like this is something
lynette scavo
might have done you know so it wasn't
actually she did do it there's an
episode where she tries to get her twins
into like a prestigious kindergarten and
she like offers to write them a check or
something oh that's so funny so
i i don't know it's interesting i
it'll be interesting to see what happens
with lori in the next year because also
felicity did get out in october
so like a year has passed it's been a
year whoa yeah
no it's crazy but it's just like
watching the two
court cases and then like the subsequent
fallout and how they both come back
if lori does choose to come back i
didn't know felicity was like
this has been this is big news i think
that she's even coming back to acting
like she could just retire william h
macy is still
on shameless he makes a lot of money she
made a ton of money like they could just
like retire
they could retire but it's also big news
that you know she got a job you know
it's both it's like her the fact that
she decided to do it and that they would
let her back like
networks are so notoriously like uh
controversy averse like in just like
big media companies and corporations
like they're so lame like they smell
like even the smallest bit of
controversy and they just like
want nothing to do with it they just
like draw people left and right so i do
find it really interesting that felicity
duffman was able to like get a job
yeah i do too this show sounds
interesting but a comedy felicity
huffman we'll see
yeah i don't know if i'll be watching it
but i will definitely be watching the
course of
felicity huffman's career yes that's
what that's the show i'll be tuning in
to
next up some more love is in the air
mean girl star matthew
meanwhile star jonathan bennett is
engaged yes
to tv host james vaughn very sweet yeah
you know
jonathan bennett had like a really
interesting life i feel like i know it's
like
there was such a lull yeah in the last
10 years and now
with all like the mean girls reunions
and the hallmark movie like
and his hosting capabilities yeah but
also i feel like he's like now
sort of like an influencer because of
the way that he engages digitally
with his past content
100 i agree with you like there was
after mean girls you would think like he
played like
the hot guy aaron samuels like a teenage
dream
in one of the biggest like teenage
movies
of all time and you would think like
that would make him into like the next
brad pitt but then i think after the
movie like there was just like no
traction for him
and i know that for a few years he was
just like quietly hosting on the food
network of that cupcake bake-off show i
think it was called like um
what was that show where they like they
had um like
different bakeries across the country
like participate in like cupcake
challenges
towards the end and they would like
become the cupcake hater for like some
event i think it was called like
it wasn't called unwrapped cupcake wars
something like that
and um he was like quietly doing that
job and like every time i would tune in
i'd be like is that aaron samuels
and then he really parlayed that into
some stuff like it's actually quite
impressive
yeah and like we said a few weeks ago
he's now in a hallmark
channel christmas movie called the
christmas house and that's the first
hallmark movie featuring a gay couple
correct yes fabulous and so he's engaged
to who
james vaughn who's a tv host so there's
a couple of hosts getting married a
couple of hosts getting married i feel
like this is just a good year
for him and i'm happy for someone who's
having a good year yeah jealous but
happy yes what happened definitely nice
news uh
a fifth and final story a little loss of
love news
what brandon blackstock is seeking 436
thousand dollars in monthly support from
our queen kelly clarkson can i tell you
something like oh kayla clarkson i don't
know if this is like bad to say
because i really am like all for
equality of genders like i
like to a fault i would say like i'm so
gen like i just think like there
shouldn't be
any sort of inequality but something
about like a man
wanting spousal um from a woman it's
like get your own job [ __ ] you know
like if a woman were to do it i'm like
just do it you know like maybe that's
just because i'm biased as a woman but
like
i don't know something about like you're
like team woman yeah but like something
about like
a man like wanting spousal support like
makes me sick
like i know that's i know that's crazy
to say because i'm so for gender
equality but like
it makes me sick sorry i'm sorry that
you're so sick
i'm sick okay how much money you want
and also because and that's an obscene
amount
yeah and she was granted primary
physical custody of their two children
um so he's requesting 436 000 in monthly
spousal and child support but like
where's the child support going if she's
the primary custody queen
i think that might be a big element of
why i feel the way that i do because
like more often than not
pending like some like crazy you know
situation the kids go with the with the
moms like the mom needs
or it's joint in which case yeah the if
there's a parent who's not working
they need spousal support to provide for
the children when the children are with
them
yeah no something about just like really
wealthy people getting divorced and like
how it all like
spreads it like really is so interesting
to me like i think the fact that jeff
bezos says wife like got half of amazon
was like
the best thing ever and like i'm so here
for that um but in this particular
situation i'm just not here for brendan
like trump
coming for kelly's change yeah whoever
brenden
is that not his name brandon whatever uh
a source told
the people that he has people
the people sorry i was gonna say the
publication but the publication is
people people yeah
people magazine that he has been quote
un equally unreasonable in his request
for child and spousal support as well as
attorney fees kelly's offered to pay for
all the kids expenses
but brandon seems to think he's entitled
to and needs 301 thousand dollars
in spousal support and 135 000 in child
support per
a month that's insane six million
dollars a year
his request is granted he would pocket
more than 5.2 million dollars per year
to care for himself
their daughter river rose and their son
remington alexander even though kelly
has agreed to cover all the costs of all
the kids everything and to take care of
them 100 of them i feel like
kelly is a lot of things and one of
those things she's a reasonable person i
don't think she's trying to like
scam her husband i think she just wants
everything to be fair i think she's a
fair person
and this is insane yeah i mean i don't
know all the
background and ins and outs but this
just seems unreasonable
and like taking advantage yeah this is
giving me marriage story vibes and of
course like i'm on team kelly
always always it's like i'm on the voice
and i'm on team kelly always
this is so sad how much money you think
kelly clarkson has i feel like she's
like so much
yeah i feel like she's always like since
she became famous has been making really
good business and financial decisions
and like good jobs and she's never
become irrelevant like she's had lulls
highs and lows but she's always worked
she's always toured she's always
released music
and i feel like she'd never live like a
crazy life like she was like this humble
life in nashville so
i feel like she must have like a 100
million dollars oh i don't know
that's a lot but also i feel like like
now she's in peak kelly season which is
crazy
you get paid like 25 million dollars a
year to do the voice like you get paid
crazy amounts of money yeah
well maybe not 25 million but i remember
like that's her talk show
the talk show's huge her music her music
she has a children's book she writes
songs for other people which is like a
great way to make money
um but no i remember on x factor they
used to release how much people were
getting paid
and like demi lovato the season with
demi lovato britney spears britney
spears got paid 25 million and yes
britney spears is like
huge and so that's probably really high
but i know like all the american idol
people they make
so much money for that season like
because it's a huge network and it's a
huge show so
yeah no you're right that must be one of
her biggest streams of income
nice i'd love to take a look at her
books cook them a little
i mean maybe if like things get really
messy you might see that yeah
i'll step in no no like sometimes that
information is published when we found
out how much like gina kirschenheiter
was making
yeah that was like a sad divorce like
that whole thing this divorce
um tv recap i really want to talk about
lost as just like conceptually and
if you've never seen it please don't
tell me i'm spoiling it just you guys
it's the show is 10 years old 20 years
okay um and the tv recap segment is
brought to you by vega
and vega has one goal to help you power
your story with premium plant-based
nutrition that enables you to feel and
perform your best
if you want to learn more about how to
power your story with vega go to
myvega.com
toast that's m y v e g a
dot com slash toast if you're looking to
upgrade your daily nutrition with your
smoothie or level up your afternoon
snack
vega has you covered from protein
powders to bars made with real
plant-based ingredients
power your story with the number one
plant-based protein powder brand in
north america
and you can learn more at myvega.com
toast
if you love to cook and you want to
upgrade some of your recipes with vega
you can use their products that are made
with real plant-based ingredients
um they're gluten-free non-gmo project
verified and vegan certified
so if you're looking to just change up
your smoothies your snacks and
you just like like to get wild in the
kitchen um and you want
some plant-based protein check out
myvega.com
toast again that link is myvega.com
toast they also have a new program vega
one and vega protein and greens
with delicious protein powders and daily
vitamins made with real plant-based
ingredients
you can nourish yourself from the inside
out learn more about vega and all their
fabulous products
at myvega.com toast love it
okay so i'm about 30 episodes in to
lost which is literally the beginning of
season two like it is the longest show
like that's what you're always asking
for
yeah and it definitely has like we first
started at me and ben were like this is
amazing and then it really just gets
like dry
and there's so much about it that i
actually don't like
and i just find it really interesting
because i think like when it was on tv
and i wasn't watching it live like so
many of my friends
were it was like as big as game of
thrones like the ending everyone was
like
like it was like this whole big drama
and i think maybe just so much has
changed in the last
10 years since loss was on like i just
don't think it's that great
like it's good it's a very good show i
mean that was like
in the day when it's like abc fox
they were making the best show they were
making the best shows right and lost was
the best of the best now with all the
streaming services it's like there are
so many quality
amazing incredible shows that you'll
probably never even get around to
watching because there's just so much
content out there like
the bar is just completely raised it is
right yeah so
i'm i'm not let i don't think i don't
think that makes lost a bad show no but
like
in the age of like game of thrones the
crown
all of you we're living in the golden
age of television
shit's creek like lost is just like
one one of many yeah so it's not a bad
show by any means it's definitely like
super interesting and you like really
grow to love some of the characters
but i just it's just killing me like
what the [ __ ] happened to them like i
just want to know the ending so bad and
it's killing me not to look it up
because it's like getting a little
boring and i'm only on season two and
i've heard that seasons one through
three are the best i'm like so this is
the best
oh so maybe you'll skip to the end but
your husband inspired me because he said
that he like loved it so much
yeah he watched it recently do you know
how it ends i feel like i know how it
i've heard things from um just like not
from him but from like
chatter yeah so i'm like almost sure i
know how it ends
what do you think i don't want to say it
why because i just don't want people
like yelling me like i just don't want
to say it
but um i'm like pretty sure i know what
happens
but i don't want to say it because like
maybe i'm wrong i don't know i don't
know why i think that it's just like
in my brain you know yeah i think
something we might be thinking the same
thing 100
and it's totally how it ends but um it's
good i don't know if i would like
recommend it like hardcore now i'm 30
episodes in so i'm like definitely gonna
like finish it
but it's hard because usually i watch
shows on my own and so much of my job is
like watching tv and recapping it's like
i watch tv pretty much all day
but ben like has a real job and when i
can't watch till like six o'clock when
it gets home it's like
i'm moving so slow now yeah that's good
balance
yeah i guess i'm watching the newest
season i'm married at first sight
and i do the do the meredith first side
fans called it maths yeah they do call
it maths which i which i learned
and the first two episodes all the
couples just got married there's four
couples and honestly like i was getting
emotional like it was
wait explain it to me when did i meet
okay so i felt like
before i watched married at first sight
like i thought it was an insanely stupid
show like stupid concept like where they
just pluck two people and then have them
get married and then like
like go figure it out yeah but it's
really not like that like there's
thousands of candidates they whittle
down to 100 they whittle it down to 50
they go to their homes
they have like a sociologist come a love
doctor pastor
to talk with these people and really
find the best match from like the
thousands of men and women that had
applied and they choose four couples
sometimes three the season they chose
for
who are compatible in every way of life
you know in their faith in the way that
they're messy or clean like things like
that like they really
do their due diligence and these people
who have signed up for the show
they're not like thirsty bachelor
contestants right they are people who
for one reason or another like have not
been able to find love on their own
right they like really seem like decent
people who
want to who want a partner and like want
to be married and just like be done with
it not to like
go on the show together to have a career
i'm sure there are people who come in
like that with like alterium road lives
but like
this season especially it really feels
like these people like really want love
and and
they're obviously like being attracted
to the person is a big part of a
relationship but it's not the only thing
and like when you meet the person they
meet on their wedding day
okay can they can they turn back i don't
know
i've i've not heard of anyone turning
back but it's like if someone were to
turn back it would mean that they
weren't there for the right reason
because you have to expect
that the person isn't going to look like
what you
your dream like right of course what do
you look like
yeah right so they meet on their wedding
day their families meet they have like a
wedding ceremony and they have like some
time to talk but everything is like kind
of really awkward
but the way that these people are just
like so excited and happy and like their
parents are like i never
does the show like coordinate the
wedding like plans it i think so because
all the weddings look the same okay
and their parents like went from having
you know a 30 year old single
child who hasn't had a relationship in
10 years to like a
son-in-law right daughter-in-law and
like they're getting married and like
they're really it's really joyous
and i was just getting emotional like
that these people and i really think
that this season nine like the couples
that they found like
are gonna work i think there are some
like real
i think like three out of four of them
could work wow but then i saw like the
previews for the season like people are
packing up oh always people are i've
seen that bars with people on reality
shows like love to pack their bags
no so like it's it could go either way
um the episodes are like really slow but
i just i have so much more respect for
like the show and the concept now be
seeing like how much goes into it and
that like it's not like they just
plucked two people and like get married
because
you want to be married so people have
been really wanting us like dive into
like the tlc reality show sphere so i'm
glad you're doing married at first sight
and obviously i think one of their
biggest shows is 90 day fiance before
the 90 days
and i've actually seen quite a few
episodes because tpg is obsessed with it
is like always trying to get me to watch
it
but some i know it's like a funny show
but somehow like i always end up like
feeling really sad like
because some of these people just make
such bad decisions and i know that it's
real like
i saw this episode where this girl like
wait so it's 90 day fiance what does
that mean
uh i don't really get it it's like and
what's before the 90 days they're dating
i don't know what before the 90 days is
or 90 days the other way they have like
a million spin-offs but 90 day fiance is
people
it starts with people in america who
have like met people online or over the
phone who live in other countries
and decided to get engaged to get like
the k90 visa where it's like you have to
live together for 90 days i don't
understand the whole thing but something
it's something legally
but like i just see these people making
horrible decisions like this one girl
who like lived in oklahoma
who um had never met this guy before she
went to
visit him i forget where he lived um
maybe morocco
and he was so mean to her that she like
literally left went back to oklahoma and
then wanted to go back and brought her
like four-year-old daughter to a country
where they had nowhere to stay
he was such a dick like wouldn't let him
stay and it was like the grandparents
were crying begging like leave the kid
with us
it was so upsetting like that's
upsetting so i don't get why people like
the show it makes me want to cry like
it's so sad
that is really sad that's not like what
married at first sight is except
i did watch the most recent episode and
there was actually like a really cute
couple this girl like arielle from new
jersey who married this really sweet
like ethiopian guy
and he was like they got pregnant and
she like delivered the baby in ethiopia
and like he was so happy and like
actually they were actually kind of cute
but i just i can't run the risk of
feeling sad i can't watch stuff that
makes me sad
yeah no i don't think that this would
make you sad i think it's like
really interesting it's a really
interesting concept concept it's like
crazy that it's a show but it's also
like
they're not just like trying to make
television like i really do think that
the people who make these matches
are invested in the matches like being
incorrect because it's they're legally
blind binding marriages like right
literally deciding two people like if
you want to get out you have to get a
divorce
right which is crazy yeah um all right
so that's our tv recap segment we have
the bachelorette on tonight
right nothing else no nothing else wow
now like last night i was like what am i
gonna watch it now like this week it
revs up tuesday wednesday thursday just
like hits you hard like
oc outside salt lake city housewives the
bachelorette southern charm
yeah used to be kardashians now the
kardashians is over so it's just
it's a great week to be a fan of reality
television it's a great week to be a
toaster
always thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every morning monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
haven't read a cat box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts
find us the morning toast and leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day and
we'll see you guys tomorrow for hump day